who are we where are we one of these
people that means good morning in
Spanish we made our bed we had some
breakfast some coffee now we're like
okay let's get this day going so
apparently you don't want to get it
going huh I said apparently we don't
want to get it going
I know based on your tone I know I have
this issue that I've been dealing with
this dislike illness this disease that
has this parasite that's infected me
with firm within laziness oh my god
that's the inside joke for one of our
first dates so when we got when we first
started dating we went to go see what
was it called Prometheus yes and then um
it was like a 3d video movie so I had
photos of us with the 3d glasses and
this is when Casey had his long hair so
it was like the beginning beginning and
when we first started dating and then in
that movie they they have like a
parasite alien and then like was it a
girl she got pregnant yeah yeah as you
can see like the alien movie that's how
it actually looks like when you're
pregnant too but moving oh yes for a
long time no second Sancta oh yeah the
laziness parasite
get it out but I have to do we got to do
some stuff today's plan is to shower
brush our teeth so check that off the
to-do list it's tough out in these
streets these lazy streets but anyway
okay the first thing that I can talk to
you guys about that I'm staring at right
now is that right there you know what
this is
don't be prepared daringly for those of
you that don't know where we have
invested into all these different food
concepts one of them is sip matcha which
has now been rebranded to be called Jun
B and the reason why we rebranded is
because we wanted to be able to have
this brand reach further and be a
stronger brand because the word sip is
widely used and especially when it's a
matcha drink shop so we wanted to create
a stronger brand and Jun B means in
Japanese to prepare to get ready right K
and in Chinese and in Chinese and in
Korean it sounds like Jun be and
apparently if enemies to and I know
Asian languages have this determinant
and Cantonese gen babe clothes to
prepare to prepare tea right with some
action for life or whatever exactly and
so that's the message behind it and
that's the reason why we rebranded and
so during this meeting they were showing
us a new merch some Jun be matcha the
these are single-serving packets which
now you will leave with you a better
than wherever
yeah so the canister so usually it comes
in a canister and they yeah and then so
but yeah this is like brand sinking you
I don't know if it's available yet maybe
you could check out website and all that
will be in the description but yeah like
it says
yes it module 1 this is what the
containers and then so we have this bowl
where you're supposed to do it like the
traditional way and a whisk and so it
kind of looks like this super tiny I
don't know if you can make that up
or like right here too but yeah now we
have these individual packets that is
branded and we could just take them
anywhere and it's so pretty I love the
branding too I like it a lot
anyway yeah that's one of the things are
I'm really excited about right now I
missed a meeting so it isn't my first
time yeah we also have reusable straws
some metal straws and they say June be
on it right there t-shirts
join me I'm down with this yeah this
looks like June be right here ok Oh our
entire bedroom is branded for June
because it's all like nature eat your
wood and then the yellow though the most
important other thing is June be that
the main palette color for June B is the
yellow exactly makes Indumati I mean
it's like this this is the color palette
for Jimmy
yeah but yeah so that's one of the food
concepts that were involved in and then
there's also like shrimp daddy to to
dango Jun B wing chicks which is our
newest concept that's something in the
works another thing which I have talked
about is big mood merch so this is our
very first design and it's Valentine's
Day limited release the next logo design
that we want to release is our actual
big news logo so keep an eye out for
that one on the house working on the
house today we're gonna go visit the
house Casey went to visit the house
yesterday while I was filming big mood
and we now have wood floors and I can't
wait to see them in person and we also
have like some faucets like in the
master bathroom and all that anyway you
guys will see later cuz that's the plan
we're gonna go visit the house and then
we're gonna go see aunt Kristina and I
believe David's gonna join us and we get
to see baby Enzo and baby Leia
and go have fun with their friends Casey
needs to open a package that has been
sitting in our living room for a few
days now that I'm like dude you got to
hurry up and open this cut received many
stern warnings and I will do that okay
so let me explain what they are stern
warnings so um I was shopping on Amazon
for some for some PJs for myself and
then I'm like hey see doesn't they have
any PJs so I bought him a whole bunch of
clothes and like other things because
Amazon has the the Wardrobe Amazon
wardrobe thing where you can buy clothes
or like pretty much create your own
wardrobe box and then it it's sent to
I'm not sponsored by the way so I ended
up creating this wardrobe box through
Amazon for Casey which is picking a
whole bunch of clothing items and then
it gets delivered to your home and then
you get to try them on and whatever you
don't want to keep your return it but
they give you a limited time to return
it I believe I don't think they're super
strict could still Amazon ooh pretty
sure that we could return it whenever
but anyway that's that's what's
happening here so I'm like Casey you
gotta try on the stuff that I that I
ordered for you and this wardrobe box
thingy so whatever you don't all we have
to return and like I said before I'm the
worst person when it comes to returning
so I'm really setting myself up for
failure here but I'm trying to change
and be better because it's a new year so
as I'm like keeping come on you gotta
try these things on so like that yeah
cuz you've been wearing this hat and the
other champion hat and then you have a
certain thing that happens to your head
that gets a little sour and it gets a
little stinky yeah my head is extra oily
for some reason it does if I don't wash
it very often
[Music]
it's kind of stink yeah I was thinking
we can get you some more hat option so
you can use more than just two hats at a
time yeah like the older I get and I
think maybe it's just like I'm getting
lazier with doing my hair Casey yeah I
don't think you know how to open a bad
hat well how do you how do you push us
in there you're supposed to look me huh
turn it like this and you see it here
and then you put your thumbs out the
other side yeah I thought you were
trying to open it so I'm like you gotta
unlock the latch just a loop here and I
was like get in there yeah there's a
cheat code here yeah you didn't know
that the other guys it's family all do
yeah you know something you yes join
explain weather's whiskey on your
nightstand is wrong or rum sorry yeah I
don't know alcohol so I'm like it looks
like we're alcoholics
oh it's not really because you pointed
out early because I was like yeah looks
like I'm an alcoholic
oh no oh right and then you're like well
not really because you don't drink very
much do you shut up Mike Haggar right
looks like we're wannabe alcoholics
right by our bed yeah last night we
started drinking gin earlier in the
evening and so then we were feeling good
but came up here we started watching
some movies and stuff and then later in
the evening I was like oh just bring up
the rum because in the back of my mind
has been stuck in my head because me
like finish watching the Pirates of the
Caribbean trilogy and in that movie like
all the pirates always takes wigs of rum
from bottles and I'm like that looks
like fun
oh my gosh do you say this to yourself
where you're like saying in front of
Isaac - no I don't think tone inceptive
oh no of course not of course that this
is like my personal thoughts yeah I am
now sharing with the vlog channel but
yeah so then I was like oh that looks
like fun and then the last thing I was
like this would be the time the try
finally he puts it on oh my goodness
this whole time he's talking I'm like
just put the head on already just put it
on just put it on you look good I like
it I like white hats I'm a fan of white
heads yeah I'm ready to go golfing
hopefully you had it's like a golfing
test you're right Tiger Woods nice a
little loose this is turning into a try
on haul I mean this is the video it's a
try on haul do you know what that is
yeah seeing clips of it it looks pretty
good is it itchy Lucy a little bit I
could see how it could be a little edgy
if you soak it with fabric softener yeah
and then wash it it shouldn't make it
soft I'll do it for you don't worry
because I know you're looking at me like
oh my god how would I do that and I was
like gibberish you know you also have
like stacks of new shirts from Amazon
you haven't even opened in the office I
need to return those the wrong side oh
my gosh you're just like me I'm not I'm
just like dang it why are we both the
same you ordered a size small but I
don't know maybe sugar got a medium this
is good
Oh because you have kind of a big booty
so I'm like oh does it fit your booty
few days pajama game PJs
petite would you still wear muscle
shirts to go to bed yeah your nipples
are hard never gets off that's funny
hey you're finally a grown-up you own
some PJ's yeah I like it I know or half
naked or we'd never make it in bed Oh
cute please but yeah you're never naked
in bed their jeans are you're in your
underwear yeah yeah I recently bought a
whole bunch of PJ's like kind of wearing
these new ones from Victoria's Secret
and stuff because we need wardrobe for
the for the podcast for a big mood
because our wardrobe is pajamas I should
have invited me after we got PJs
so that can be on the podcast but PJs
well you were you were wearing you were
wearing some sweatpants that you had
it's just that you don't use those for
PJs use them like I don't know just to
be around the house these are the same
size I don't think you need to try these
on tops you know cuz I'm kind of school
you know yeah you're so full like so
tool all right what do you think about
these PJs
[Music]
oh I don't like them as much because
well these look the cutting is really
big I can mix stepping on the pants yeah
I have a lot of PJs that fit me a really
long but the whole point is to be loose
and comfy yeah sure yeah well maybe I
don't know I'm too small Oh shorts
PJ's shorts Oh PJ shorts that
[Music]
I know cuz you walk around in that so
for you you're like Landor are my short
why you should get Isaac TJ short he has
them he likes being in his underwear to
good father like son
yep cute oh right
you scared the cat you're better
there you go so are you keeping
everything are you returning the you
keeping your people
GIM Chi su is kind of tight I don't know
honestly I would prefer to not return
anything because then I don't have to
worry about it yes but I don't want you
to keep it and then never wear it
because it doesn't fit you success
fashion Hall complete there we go
[Music]
she's playing look at his little like
mouth
[Music]
and scaring him away okay
papacito we gotta go
I thought I was helping are you are you
are you know oh really it was very it
was very easy my left wrist you helped
me
okay well I'm all showered let's go are
we gonna go eat some dinner we're gonna
just eat something here or what are we
gonna do I don't know
we need someone to make decisions for us
I don't want to make decisions it's the
lazy parasite the parasite you got any
to know gauges I'm sorry look at it it's
so - are you so lazy though where are we
we're here and Christina right now is
holding and sewing he really needed to
burp and so I put him on my chest and we
got the birth bell which you could check
out and Christina's channel cuz he cut
in and then you got the aftermath yeah
they're proof but what did you do Oh
instant replay collect what do I do you
taste
instincts thank you I just didn't want
to get I don't know my instincts wasn't
so much the Daddy instinct so it was
more like who don't don't get it dirty
but I'll take the daddy compliment do
though like I was dirty here you go
here's your baby back
okay look yeah finally got that perfect
but he is dealing with his hiccups
that's true but putting him on my chest
though that was the first time I've done
that to a baby since Isaac like I like I
usually hold him like you know the
regular way but not this way cuz this is
how I used to always hold I do the
newborn he was always like straight up
he didn't really like being laid down so
like he seriously looks like your baby
yeah last time ya know I'm like I'm
waiting in line right behind you look at
this boy he's like I am so okay he's
instructing me I don't know yeah just
put your arms out there we go that's all
he's got his neck that was easy
[Music]
okay he does look like your kid look at
natural holes you're like this way too
much yeah you got some blonde hair here
I think really light how cute come on
patch oh it's his Italian side coming
out
the ins okay so he's not having I don't
think you should that way yeah now when
you go home you could practice a holding
Isaac like that sure alright just
staring at each other hmm
it's so fun like I looked forward to the
day where you just stare at a baby like
your own baby it's like oh I know I did
I didn't sleep for two weeks no just I
was so sleep-deprived I'm like you're
just so perfect
[Laughter]
can't wait to experience that baby gonna
be fun mm-hmm but anyway so yeah we came
to an Christina's singing ends up for a
bit Laius taken a nap or we came to
kidnap the new mama for kidnapping me oh
yeah and tell you that I I'm always in
the house and he's always like you
should go do this and go run an errand
for me or something just to get out I'm
like no I don't I know girl trust me I
know the mom guilt I've been there and I
can't even imagine what it's like with
two kids yeah but I also know how
insanely like how insanely draining it
could get it's like mentally like mental
health wise you know like just being at
home all day no matter how much you love
being at home just being at home all day
every day for a long at time it really
messes with your head a bit so I don't
know your feeling I'm not trying to say
that you're feeling any sort of way I'm
just like because from my own experience
I can only imagine if you might be
experiencing any sort of like yeah I got
some cabin fever going on so we want to
kidnap you and go take us to go take you
to our new house oh so you can go either
okay so that's the plan I'm in if you
think yeah but no it's okay
I got clear to work out the other day
and then no night I went to work out for
like 30 minutes and then I go checking
the camera to see like Holloway osc yeah
and I was like thinking about him and
I'm like telling him all the hey can you
check on me I don't know
so I totally feel that good I'm telling
you I couldn't shower without staring at
Isaac like he had to be in the in the
little like Besant that thing right next
hour yeah see me with Leah - yeah girl I
understand totally get it but we're
kidnapping you also laughing a smile
funny I mean you got a workout his face
muscles and you're gonna move his arm I
just see him like figuring it out yeah
figuring it out Enzo oh yeah I know
right the last time you came it was dirt
I know there's nothing now there's a
whole house I know I got which doors
dope
[Music]
[Applause]
nothing they are huge huge look so clean
[Music]
these tiles this backsplash was
definitely like a big the biggest gamble
we had in terms of like choosing or the
style of this place that are definitely
off an experiment aw 'king about getting
rid of the blue here but this is so cool
matches your hair the last vlog I was
literally standing here were you talking
about my hair
yeah and her sing big sink it makes a
huge difference
[Music]
what of you the porta-potties right in
front of my beautiful it's great don't
think usually to install that and I got
the bond there's like that puffy piece
so they usually put oh it's already
there hilarious in the in the video it
looks like a big backyard I know our tub
is finally installed dang this is what
isn't wide enough for you both of you
[Music]
yeah no this is definitely bigger
because we do shower together and our
current bathroom or like really fit very
yes Wow Ruby still lame
yeah rocket rocket it's double-sided on
the other side just kind of put a big
shower curtain there yeah we just talked
about that this morning we're any ice
cream
I'm gonna get myself
fruits
and you look thick
I know you're getting wet or you want to
see us me they they love us no you don't
need a lot yeah they the us yeah that's
my favorite you're a good friend I feel
so useless I only have one thing in my
hand
technically I'm also holding big rise in
here you don't know what it is yet
I don't keen give me oh I know you have
it oh you played along though thank you
for you ending me yeah yeah I know it
was
[Music]
[Music]
paperclip now yeah David my name Jose
kid yeah through that be the day when
all of us have kids man oh it's getting
there with getting there slowly we had
the same thought - we had the same time
just get just be done with it right
ideally a boy and girl twin and then
we're just time there we go that's the
plan oh yes let me show oh yeah yep the
goodies
[Applause]
[Music]
what is that
[Music]
salsa Getty this is like that yeah yeah
that like gum ISA this is oh that's my
favorite
this is a Tamron yeah Tamron there's
also like tamarind peanuts and he come
out and mango spice oh yeah cucumbers in
the bottom I got more sauce and I'll put
more on there yeah you're the most
Mexican Asian I've ever met I'm setting
the standard you know for all baby
showers you want it very Mexican yes
I'll have a taquitos this time maybe a
hard tacos this time some burritos a
brittle Stan yeah or some dim sum yeah I
can get it done some car to Chicopee
only yes perfect big tarts
there we go that's how you do it Friday
eight tarts and then a Hong Kong style
milk tea with some [ __ ] trying to mix
yeah I'm not bored about that Oh Oh Dada
and lights on mix together how about
that I got tired of my my ice cream I
think I'm done with it nuts
I'm just not it's a nut flavoured ice
cream
oh yeah I mean it's knew it knew it but
it's not new as next to English next to
the word
was nuts it's wet yes keep saying new
words but I got em Palin god oh my from
that which means what it means that it's
too sweet
no sweet now yeah look at that
no spoonful of thinking keep dying over
here
ruined it for you because you just had a
whole thing that they keen like won't
taste anything after this you just
destroyed your taste buds what do you do
oh that's what that is
[Music]
thank you oh oh you're okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you all right and left her it got
out
[Music]